well you one thing to remember uh with
with these judges and this is a problem
with the system is that they often work
in the same like in my town they're
they're effectively offices are in the
same building as the prosecutors
um and and they're in when they're not
in their offices they're just in court
and they have these cattle call hearings
and so you're sitting there with the the
prosecutor their their co-workers for
five hours straight as they go through
uh this this big stack of files defense
attorneys you know file in and out and
some of them get get friendly but but
the other issue that the judge can
always fall back on is well um yeah
in this case kyle would have been
prejudiced if he was found guilty but he
wasn't prejudiced because the jury came
to the right conclusion so since there's
no harm you know it really doesn't look
good to do it uh to go back and revisit
this issue and that's why i was on the
same page with you uh once he said well
why don't we we could put you guys on
the stand uh under oath and get an
expert in here i'm like yeah do it judge
dismiss the journal 10 minutes
dismiss the jury for the day for a week
whatever you need however long you need
to get an expert let's put these
prosecutors on the scene let's get them
under oath talking about how they
emailed it to their personal gmail
account from their gov account and then
and then sent it when everything else
was sent by dropbox
explanations 30 seconds on that laptop
and i can tell you if he did it or not
30 seconds you pull up the log files and
you can see what they did
like that yep
10 minutes
10 minutes to put them on the stand
jerry can wait have a bag of doritos
while they're waiting a little give them
some pop give them some pepsi now the
other person that can do something with
that
is kyle yep right it you know putting
aside the defamation stuff
one instance because it's basically that
case i would take if i were advising him
i would take that to federal court for a
violation of his civil rights right
that's what happens when you have
prosecutorial misconduct at the state or
federal level your best bet is this
whole thing that you see in the movies
like i'm going to sue you for melissa's
prosecution that doesn't really exist
it's like really hard
yeah like one in a bazillion but what
you can do i mean suing for a violation
of civil rights is also very difficult
but it's very it's very real in this
case this guy this kid was charged with
capital murder and the prosecution
doctor as evidence that's pretty damn
good now what you'll have to prove in
federal court is hey man you won your
trial well okay my life's now screwed up
because of this because i was labeled a
domestic terrorist falsely a terrorist
falsely a racist falsely you know member
of the cake whatever he he's got a good
list to make that case well and he's got
a bunch of
news news organizations dutifully
reporting that he raised his gun and
provoked uh and provoked the attack and
that the the ruling is unjust because of
that so um the the news can kind of feed
this in and if he's got civil attorneys
or if he's got prospective civil
attorneys
who are thinking about things like this
uh you know hopefully they'll be
capturing those things and and it's it's
not going to go against the news
companies but it's going to say this is
the result of the state infringing on my
client's civil rights and here's the
damage that was done because now it's
it's all over the major media that he
provoked an attack that he never did
yeah and real quick sorry luke you can
quantify damages from a media sense in
terms of pr
uh rectification or whether right where
would be basically if they dedicate
one minute
in defaming you and you need to then pay
one minute to counter that lie it's very
expensive
if you guys weren't if you guys were
kyle's lawyers what would be your first
step who would you go after first in
this entire matter the prosecutors the
media the state how would you how would
you navigate that that field
man
whatever he's going to do is going to be
tough
at the end of the day he won
and
we were talking about libel proof
earlier
part of the problem with the way we
prosecute things is if any opinion out
there is based on the prosecution itself
based on what's in the complaint people
are able to formulate reasonable
opinions based on that now uh there are
issues because a lot of the stuff that's
being reported by some of these places
never happened for example saying that
kyle shot three black men that never
happened so that's not really a subject
of the complaint that's a way to attack
but i mean for my for my money uh i'm
going after kraus and the county of
kenosha and by extension the state of
wisconsin um on the deprivation of civil
rights i think that's a that's a great
approach um to take and then for
defamation it's going to be based on
individual news publications and what
they've said wasn't it the guardian the
other day that said he shot three black
guys the independent the independent uh
so that's going to be tough because
that's in the uk uh so that
unless they have a us office i believe
they do a vos office okay so you might
be able to go after them but you're
really going to have to do very careful
sifting as we saw with sandman right
they had something like 57 statements
and only three went through because
almost all of them are opinion anything
that says kyle's a white supremacist
that he's a racist uh that he was
racially motivated those are gonna
probably be opinion statements but they
all said he crossed state lines the gun
that's a statement of fact right right
that's that's that's a
on its face a defense defamatory
statement then the next thing so kyle's
kyle's a little bit of a different um
he's differently situated than almost
anyone else would be right the second he
got arrested this case went global right
so what they will argue is not against
the defamation they will argue that
kyle's a public figure right so once you
become a public figure man that
defamation hurdle is huge it is you in
order to show damages you have to
satisfy this bar that's almost
impossible to satisfy even if you prove
kyle did not cross state lines with a
gun kyle did not shoot three black men
kyle is not a domestic terrorist he's
not a racist or a member of whatever
that's the what i would recommend to
kyle and his crew is that i would write
an open letter to the department of
justice for them to initiate a federal
civil rights investigation of the
kenosha county prosecutor's office and
the police that investigated this case
because they have done that repeatedly
in the past when there has been racial
unrest and cities were burning that's
doj's biggest civil war i think the doj
is more likely to go after kyle no i
agree i would just make this i would do
that right as part of a sort of a
grander media strategy to be like we
asked the department to come in and do x
they said no now i have my rights under
defamation and this and that and what
other options do you guys think the
tucker carlson documentary complicates
this because it kind of paints him as a
public figure always look whenever
you're making statement like you never
hear me talking about my defamation
cases except to say the pleadings are
public the instance is there they lied
about this meeting that's all i say if
you give an interview on that these
lawyers are going to go in there and
just tear you apart and use that in
pleadings yeah because tucker carlson
was filming a documentary on kyle during
the entire court proceeding so which i
agree with kyle's defense lawyer yeah i
would have been like no way no you're
out you cannot cannot be here but it's
kyle's choice at the end of the day yeah
if it's kyle's choice at the end of the
day it might be someone else's choice
uh we don't really know but i'm really
glad you mentioned the the
the media the grander media strategy
because um we're talking about how hard
these cases are to win that doesn't mean
that a defamation case can't be valuable
yes whether whether you win or not you
know kyle's got this big dilemma he's 18
years old and he's facing a life where
his name will forever be tainted by what
happened to him
and uh that's really unfair but a
defamation case can be a way to launch
himself into
uh if he wants to embrace a media
spotlight he can become a spokesman a
spokesman against stuff and a defamation
case is a way to do that talk about the
the broken
prosecution system talk about the fact
that media can run roughshod over people
raise a lot of money doing it get some
sponsorships behind him and and become a
media figure in the way that uh you know
some of the parkland kids have done um
yeah you know they they've taken that
you know obviously different uh side of
the political spectrum but there there
is a way to make a career out of that
when otherwise his careers prospects got
chopped down considerably from the
average 18 year old
let me ask you in if if you're a public
figure or involuntary public figure i
think what they call this the covington
kids then the standard would be
actual malice or gross negligence
regarding the facts right it's it's
actual malices for for any public figure
so but
doesn't it also include gross negligence
no that's different
really like actual malice gross
negligence really i thought even if
you're a public figure then
like your intent it's your intent so you
so
even though
if you watch the trial for even 10
minutes
even even though you could look at any
of the filings
when they lie about when they say he
crossed state lines the gun
right now even though dominic black is
currently in in being prosecuted
literally for giving the gun to to kyle
in wisconsin
that's not actionable
so the the actual malice standard from a
journalistic perspective is that
the journalists and this is this is so
frustrating the journalistic uh outlet
has to have a standard that they would
typically do to conduct research and
they have to fail to meet that standard
that's the gross negligence i think
you're talking about right is is that
they still that's how you show actual
malice is if they have a standard and
then they fail to meet the research
standards that they would otherwise do
okay right okay so i will tell you this
then if kyle rittenhouse files a loss he
absolutely should sue every single one
of these outlets because i will love it
when they're like our standard does it
include using google we we don't take 10
seconds to google search any of these
things we just say them because we made
them up but here's the here's the kicker
i'll be happy this is part of the reason
i'm out there like raising all this
money for people's defamations lawsuits
it's not just yes there's insane amount
of value in bringing cases that have
some merit right but like you said the
biggest obstacle is money so i'll you
know we'll take care of that and fight
with cash we'll pay for your lawyers and
we'll review your case for free but the
other kicker in bringing defamation
suits if you bring them in the right
state courts it's that they have to
divulge once you get past this like
mid-trial phase called summary judgment
they the defense has to disclose their
sources
to this plaintiff really why is that
important because then you're because
what the judge has decided is well this
case has enough fact issue to go to a
jury i the judge i'm out of ruling on
that now here we go discovery and oh by
the way you don't want to settle you the
defense like in virginia state law which
is where all my cases are being brought
they have to once we get past summary
judgment tell me who is the sources of
your stories and if they fail to do that
it's a default judgment what if they lie
or
well
i guess they could that's always
possible but i think that's why what's
the worst so if if they say we will not
reveal our sources it's a default
judgment you win wow that's why uh devin
nunes brings a lot of cases in virginia
right yeah so devin and i uh dear friend
my former boss he actually had a huge
win in federal court um in the appellate
court about a month ago and um yeah we
bring
we just bring cases to clear our names
you know devin's a little different he's
like the public figure of public figures
right russiagate but he's doing it for
the reasons we're talking about yes he
was defamed yes they attacked his 90
year old grandmother right and he
realizes the bar is very high but what
happens is we're trying to correct the
media and the way you do that is you
issue a monetary judgment against them
the other way you do that is you take
them to federal court get past summary
judgment and get their sources and tell
the world yeah that that's the that
hurts that's one of the the strategy
when someone lies against you you you
have two options money or the truth or
both i mean hopefully you get both but
uh but a lot of people will lose a
defamation suit but uh they'll lose the
judgment but uh people will get the
option of seeing oh there's another side
of this story and those stories will
consequently get a lot of media coverage
because the initial story got a lot of
media coverage and that can have a ton
of value in itself to rehabilitate to at
least tell hey at least the people who
don't hate me you know what i didn't do
any of this stuff that they're saying
they're lying about me you know they're
lying about me and and that can have a
lot of value too the problem right now
is
if cnn came out and said you know uh
riketa
hates chocolate ice cream some you know
it's true and no no but let's say it's
not true it's not true
anybody who likes cnn
well maybe you're not a good example
let's say trump let's say cena comes out
and says trump report uh trump hates
chocolate ice cream chocolate ice cream
according to those familiar with his
thinking as they you know that
ridiculous line they like to use
anybody who likes trump is going to say
they're lying and then trouble like it's
not true i love chocolate ice cream and
then anybody who hates trump is going to
believe cnn right right so it's like
there's almost no point even bothering
except for monetary damages
it it depends uh it depends on the
polarization of the figure i mean trump
is an extremely polarized figure
more than probably anyone else on earth
right um but for uh for devin nunes you
know for someone who's maybe um 75
percent of the way to trump's level of
polarization uh i i think there's value
there i i really do thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time